.
OVERALL CRIME   22% DURING THAT
INTROLS ON TWO
FIVE YOUORTSN ON PRECINCTS. IN S
WITH A
THEY RECOGNIZE ONE OF E
R PREVIOL D CANNOT VERIF
IDENTITHEM TTHE 46 WAS ONCNO AS
DANGEROUS SQUAREIL
AMERICA.
CRIME RATES IN NEW YORK AREN'T
FLARE NEAR TEAK  T
1990s BUEY ARE SPIKING.
>> ARE YOU SEEING THIS GETTING
WORSE AND PRTYOF THIS ?
>> Y.
GROWING UP, LI I SAID, IW
UP IN THSOUTBRONX, I'VNEVER SEE
>> SHOOTING INCIDENTS IN NEW
ERIOD LASTTOHE
IN TE OFFICERS FIND
>> AND IT SUCKS TO SEEHIS, TO ES
SEE 16-YEAR-OLD KIDS SHOOTING
AND KILLINEATHER AND THAT
IS WHAT WE S.D WE HAVH
KIDS. PATTERNS AND THEDN'T
WOR A HIT-AND-RUN
DRIVER AND WE ARRIVE
THE GROUND ANDDING.
FICERS AND
COMMANDERS AG
SIY DESC END
OF THE PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT
REDET OF,
HAVE FLO T
N NEW YORK CITY
ALNCH CHANGES
POLICINGUS
W  ENACTEDAIRER ELIMINATE JAIL N
CSENTEL
THE STREET. AT OFFENDERS BACK ON
>> I'LL STILL BE AT WORK AND 'L
I'M EVEN DONE WITHRT
>> THAT IS GOT TO BE
FRUSTRAT
SEF POLICENGAND
YEARS HAT IN
POLI AS COUNTRY.
>> THATES DANGERS FOR THE OFFICS
BEAT.
>> WE HAVE PEOPLTHREAT U
RES.
TEN TO KILR FAMILY.
>> I HOPE YOUR FAMILDIES AND, F
YOU'RE SUPSE
HIA DEBILITATING
EFFECT ON THE RANK AND FILE.
NG OFFICERS
THA COULD RECRUEW
OUTRHT FORCE.IT IS  MALS TELLE N
IM AFFECTI
ICDUT IN WHICH INFORM CE A CHOKD
SHAY SAID DEPAVE TSPONSI
OWN AGGRESSIVE.
WE M HE NEGATIVEN COUNTERS
WHERBUWIUTS OF AYEAR. INCIDEND N
SET YOU BACK SO OSTHE
SIH THE W YORK AND
AFH  GS
KILLING AND THE RISE IN CRIME,
POLICE ARE NOW DAT
RANGE OF PE POLI
>> WE HAVE AITON
TH AUR GEORGD E WE HAD HUNDREDS
HUNDREDSF THE MARC.AD TOO.
AND THEY H POINT OF VIEW.
SO I THINK W NCE, WHAT WORRIES .
AND NOTE
AND KINDF PLAY CATCH-U
WI>>IS
R USED
STOP A
FRISK.
ACCORDING TO NTWO R THE
POASONIT
SINCE NY HPATHIS AD
K T WI
OVER000 STOPS.  IT IS HOW ANG
DO YOU OVER USYO AND IN WHAT
NEIGHBORHOODS FO REASON.
THAT ION
>> EDP IS WHAT YOU HEAR,D PERSO.
ION OF THEALLSTHEY GET ANDAND WA
ALTH
IS AN EMP.
>>FF WT
REMAIN COMMITTEDO
PONGE
N.ST A FEW Y AGO, VIOLENT
CRIMS AT IDECADES.
>>ARE NEVER GOING TO
GO BACAYWE HAVE A SPIKE IN VIOL
DOLABLE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
'RE GOING TO
THOUGHWE'RE GOING TO N
HOW ARE YO B
, TH
THAT THERE ARECING A>> THE
T IS GOINGD YOU HAVE GOING
TH A SUBSTSS Y HOUSING.
>> A FORYOUNGER
BROTHE A GUNA VI
RRIA
VIHERE IS A FUSE AND DE ESCALATN
THAT IS OU ACE
CAN YOU TELL OURWERSWANTED TO G.
BE AFOR TWO NIGHTS.
WHY DIU S STORY.
WE'RE SEEING A CNOSIMPLE
ITFA
BERSC
CK AND WHI
IS NOT AOU HAVE TO
ENW HOURS OUE AND ARS OND VIOLE
, LIKE WITCHESF CAUSES AE SILEO.
NEITR ARE THE PEOPLE LIVING THE
>> IIS SUCH A GO